hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to let's play SCP
Containment sorry I had something in my
throat there for a second all right and
so anyway we got a good uh playthrough
going on here but the only problem is we
don't have the right access level card
we need to find
the machine scp-91 blah blah blah blah
but we got a good position going on here
and I'm not gonna get rid of my save for
the life of me
I knew that was gonna happen I knew that
was I'm not ready to go into his realm
just yet
I need at least to get the card
and
I opened the door to his area so I know
where it is and if I get in there then I
can get there later
or I can get out if I get ported in
there man
what the hell
what what is this
what the hell is this
what the what the Hooda what
the hell is this
I need to hire security clearance oh
this is the computer
oh yeah
that's right there's a computer I read
about him there's an SCP that's
my computer program but it's it's like a
fully sentient AI but it only has like a
limited amount of memory so that you
know
so that it only is able to
um oh man it's only able to remember
like a fudge he's in there
it's only like they're able to remember
anything for like a day here we go where
are you where are you where are you ah
come on oh no
oh
oh sorry about that guys all right also
I changed some of the settings so that
um
uh my microphone you should notice that
I sound a bit clearer than I have before
and I've tried to change some things in
that regard
but I'm having trouble remembering that
got other things on my mind thank you
very much
moving forward from here um it's just
straight shot areas
that was coming
straight shot here to um
back to the room where I was so it's not
far I'm not gonna try to save again
until something happens because I can't
I really can't risk falling through the
floor again and yep there it is again
radical Larry's being all up in like
real leg
he's in there
if I go now I can just get past him
yeah that's right got your number I like
it boss okay
stop moving around you dick makes me
think you're gonna suddenly jump in here
because that's happened before
that has happened before guys
okay usually in this area is a safe
place to save so I'm Gonna Save here
blink good good
okay here's the here that's how I summon
radical Larry as you guys so kindly
mentioned to me before but I need
God damn I need to find a level two key
card that's what I need
I absolutely need a level two key card
to even start down the path to get to
the right place
and I don't remember which way I went
it's been a while
I'm gonna try this direction
okay obviously I've been through there
but I've not been through here I never
bothered what the hell is this seriously
why am I seeing so many new things that
I have never seen before I mean
seriously I've never seen this this is
insane how do I not know about this
what is this
I did not download like a new version of
the game I just got like the world's
best
oh no come on I just got like the
world's best seed
map seed get your minds out of the
gutters come on really
what the hell you
what the hell is this
what is this there's a camera
hi
freaking following me and I hear I hear
once
oh crap
what is it what is it
oh no
oh
no no no no
this is oh my God
this is this
this holy crap
oh my
God man if anybody reads any of these
scps you gotta read this one and go to
the website to find it out it is an
incredible we read the story about this
guy is insane oh God please don't tell
me he's in this game because I
that can't be good for anybody anyway so
yeah that must be like I don't know
obviously this is just the outside of
his containment that's how much they put
into it the real containments through
those doors I bet man that's insane
that's absolutely insane
okay is this the machine found the
machine but I I can't get in here with a
level one I need a level two I need a
level two once I get that I can open up
the coffin to get to radical area
the maintenance tunnel
oh no
I know all about the maintenance tunnel
okay Gonna Save
don't what is that it's a lighter an
eyeball
okay it's a light freaking look like an
eyeball to me okay
let's see it right here no not in here
let's save right here because if I fall
through the floor I just go down to the
blow all right save I'm gonna summon
radical Larry I'm gonna make him give me
hopefully this doesn't fail on me
going down on the maintenance
okay yep he's coming he's a coming
yep
hi buddy hi how you doing friend you
good yeah that's good to hear
ah there he is okay he's ah what where
oh I know where he's coming I know he's
coming
I don't like him ah there he is oh crap
I hate him so much he's so oh God ah a
door that works what no ah come on
I found the exit no way I didn't know
that's how that worked man there's
I'm like being proven prove that there's
a bunch of things that I don't know
about this game that I really should
know okay now where is it where is it
where is it where is it where it is here
we go and the note burnt note ah Dr
George Maynard that's his door
there we go there you have it folks
when you are not paying attention I'm
going to bite you your Achilles tendon
okay sounds good oh crap almost fell off
there okay
shut up no you're not gonna get me in
here I know your tricks I know all about
your tricks
I I don't know mistakes I think I know
his tricks but I don't really know his
tricks
oh boy
here we go I'm actually wondering
because there are multiple doctors
offices I'm wondering if there's
actually a
place that I need to go I'm not risking
saving in here no no way
oh hi hey buddy
okay you just chilling out there
chillaxing in the wall okay back on here
I think I have to like go through this
three times or something that's what it
took last time
come on oh my
stay on target hard to tell where my
feet are there we go all right should be
the last round
crap what if I picked the wrong one I
don't know
there's no signs or anything let's just
go
oh boy
let's see wait I've already been through
this one haven't I crap oh come on
no
man I just can't risk saving in there
not with this one it's just it's two
it's two it's the same is too good so
I'm just gonna go down there and I'm
gonna face him as soon as he pops up
that's what I'm gonna do damn it
okay I can't go in anyone that I've been
before I don't know something like that
come on out radical Larry I want to have
a word actually no I don't want to have
a word I'm gonna go to the end and see
what's the deal with that other elevator
because that's interesting
comma I know you're there
don't come on come on come on come on ah
there he is okay
oh I go so slow
oh
come on man oh crap crap crap come on
okay if I hang on I'm gonna see what the
deal is with it
no gonna run around you no miss me oh
watch that oh fake out oh what's that
Pro dodging up all enough yeah oh crap
there's the same one isn't it okay never
mind
you got me fair and square radical Larry
and if that is your real name
okay so anyway the note is over
where is it there it is okay got the
note flip I don't even need to read it
okay this is the one oh yeah I read that
the Achilles tended one that's right oh
hello this is different
uh
oh crap
all right how about you right next to it
am I gonna die again
I swear I'm gonna be trapped in this
guy's domain forever did I just blink
out her whatever oh hello okay fine by
me
easier for me to get out of here that's
your mistake radical Larry
uh okay round one complete but now I
don't know where I am
perhaps let's just go straight ahead
because I know the burden up wasn't
straight ahead
don't say Achilles ten that says
Achilles tendon
ah crap I went to the one immediately
right of that I don't know
that's different your hair smells so
nice so thank you
there we are in round two
falling down
come on man you don't want to eat me I
don't taste good
I'm all stringy and muscly
way too much meat on my bones
okay so straight ahead was a bad option
so to the left
to the left
maggots oh crap that's a dead end never
mind how about right here is this good
I like this please don't throw me down
into the abyss
ah come on not down into the abyss ah
fudge
oh man this is gonna take forever
this is gonna be excruciating
man I wish I wish I could just get this
like I don't know how I do it on the
first try I'm gonna have to like save in
there
something
maybe if I just I don't know I'm gonna
give it one more shot and do it quickly
get it done and out
try to get in and out as fast as I can
just cut the note and get out of there
come on
where are you at where you at buddy you
came out of the walls a little farther
up last time so maybe it's gonna be that
way again
you tell me radical Larry
foreign
music
there it is
where are you
where are you at
which are coming from
where is he
ah
hey
to the freaking wall is that really the
shortest path to me really really
all right
I think I may before I start the next
episode I may just um go through this
until I can get out of it with the code
because that won't waste you guys time
so that one's okay here we go
Flip Flip
and then things go a little wonky
oh man
oh my
God okay there we go and I don't
remember which one was rich but I'll go
down this one
if this is the exact same one I'm gonna
punch myself in the nuts
have your eyes adjusted yet not yet
oh hello okay round two I can make it I
can do it maybe probably not probably
not
probably not
let's see here
go away radical Larry no one likes you
anyway whoa Walters got taller how about
this one is this gonna kill me probably
probably definitely oh this looks bad
this looks bad this is bad it's bad I
shouldn't be gone
oh
oh wait no oh no
ah come on
no no
I got out but I forgot that I didn't
have the right key card oh Balderdash
Boulder douche
order douche
that's awful that's awful that's just
I'm gonna break your femur just because
of that
but I'm Not Gonna Save after obviously
so wait hang on
foreign
I don't know I don't know okay
all right unfortunately I failed big
time on that one
God why did I waste all damage well I
mean I was hoping that it wasn't gonna
drop me in in Shadow Dimension but he
did or in his containment cell but he
did and I'm stupid and all that stuff
I'll make more progress in the next
episode I swear I will but anyway it was
really cool to see the new stuff so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotations for more videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye